you also appeared in now what is one of
the biggest films of all time as
Spider-Man no way home
[Applause]
everyone loves it everyone loves
Spider-Man yeah I went to see in the
cinema and when you guys appeared the
cheer was amazing
you know you went to see it's so cool
yeah I mean it's so you know I I
finished playing I'm far too old to be
playing Spider-Man now but they they
asked me back and and it's the sweetest
thing ever
um because I put that to bed I was like
no that's I'm I'm good I'm done that's
that's lovely um and Tom Holland is just
the best so I just kind of became a fan
again and then and then they asked me to
do it and and Toby was doing it as well
it's Toby's I'm I've got to do it Toby's
doing it as much and at least you're at
the oldest exactly
but he's my but he's my Spider-Man so
it's like you know I I would practice
his lines in the mirror when I was at
drama school like I was very high at the
time but
my friend Terry McGinnis who and he
would he would crack up and he would
look at me like yeah
but me and me and Toby we um we became
friends and we We snuck in to a theater
in Los Angeles
um on the opening weekend and we were
just too you know middle-aged white guys
and baseball hats and masks and we just
kind of yeah absorbed them I was yeah
you know special special things in the
middle of a pandemic and it's one of
those things I mean when you've had a
big success in a role like that going
back to it did it feel like a high risk
thing to do yeah it was a stupid idea
scary thing to attempt yeah especially
just the costume
oh God 38 year old man in a spandex they
are unforgiving those costumes
[Laughter]
but I heard you talking somewhere isn't
there how your height difference makes
those stunts more complicated thank you
Graeme
I didn't say it Zendaya said it
now that is a good story it's like the
story well you see there's there's a
particular stunt there I don't know if
it's in this but there's a you know he
Spider-Man swings us on top of a bridge
and he places me there that's the bridge
yeah that's the bridge we eventually
jump off of them yeah
um so he's supposed to gently you know
rest MJ on the bridge and walk away from
her
it because of our height difference I
obviously if we're on the same like
points we were attached I would land
before him because my feet obviously hit
the ground before he does
so
what would happen well there's like it's
called a bottom Mark isn't it and the
bottom Mark is to basically it's a thing
that they do in stunts that is basically
designed to stop you shattering your
kneecaps oh yeah so Zendaya would land
and I'm the superhero I'm supposed to
look cool and she would land and then I
would sort of land like this and my feet
would swing from underneath me and then
she would catch me
but you're actually very very lovely
about you were like oh my gosh thank you
it's so nice to be caught for a change
as actors I know do you need to be more
careful about what you say and do
because Johnny I heard it because
presumably because you're Johnny Depp
like I read a story about was it because
you were coming from Lima to Miami I
think when you were stopped at Customs
oh yeah yeah and and if you hadn't been
Johnny Depp they probably wouldn't have
stopped you would they well it's kind of
an interesting route anyway Lima Peru to
Miami it does sound like a drug Rod
they're already expecting things and I
did have some things
and uh yeah there was a kind of a soft
bag and and the Customs guy said
would you mind opening this up I said he
said he said first he said what is in
there I said uh stuffed piranhas
I'm sorry stuffed piranhas
and some vampire bats
unzipped and then there just happened to
be some sort of vitamin powder that I
was taking at the time
yeah I mean in all seriously
because I'd still be in jail
when I unzipped it poof you know
and then with these piranhas and bats
covered in white powder
never mind the cocaine right sorry
why did you have piranhas and bad it was
important to have them
I had to bring them home yeah but the
guy thought he found the motherlode you
know he must have been so excited oh God
it was
oh
having a two-hander he didn't go through
with it just so you know
so what did you how did you say it was
still a virgin oh I was a virgin until
Ricky
you say do you say that's a vitamin
powder don't worry about it and he
believed you
is that is that real they really do that
not believe me no right so what do they
do get everybody came out with guns and
things like that
but did you put a knife in your and go
up the rigging
you do do that thing so you when you
begin an album you bring it out and you
do the promo and you normally do a tour
or in this case it was going to be the
Vegas residency and then
yeah so what are your plans for this
Vanishing and do you know how long how
long you're going to be vanished for
um well I definitely will vanish again
um but I'm trying to like make a really
conscious effort to stop being so anal
with my privacy like I mean say that I'm
still [__] private
I'm trying to not always be two
completely different versions of myself
because it's exhausting like you know
switching on and switching off and some
of that so that's sort of why I'm sort
of like I go out for dinner a bit more
now even which I know sounds pathetic
but like what's the Worst That Could
Happen nothing yeah so
um yes I will be disappearing in terms
of my music but you might see a glimpse
of me every now and then I won't be in
complete hiding you know but do you
disappear to like recharge yeah and it
takes me a while yeah it really takes me
a while like you know it takes me about
three years yeah and then I've got to
like rev myself up to go into the studio
and then it takes me a good year and a
bit to finish an album no you hosted the
Golden Globes is it five times
five times over ten years yeah okay
because I don't know if you guys know
you probably don't know that the Golden
Globes have just sort of vanished they
didn't they didn't happen this year for
for local because of you because yeah
I'm getting that I'm getting the blame
for it I know I am yeah it was I really
it changed as well because the first
time I did it like 10 years ago the sort
of press particularly the industry press
in America was like how why is he saying
these awful things to the most beautiful
people you know and then by the fifth
time right they were going good give it
to him we're sick of celebrities so it
was quite Zeitgeist it sort of hit a
mark last time and that but I'm really
glad I did it but I think that's enough
okay you must were you in the audience
if any of Ricky's several times
it was a little bit I think it cuts to
you in one of them I think when you talk
about Jeffrey Epstein
yeah to me
yeah
but it's but it's a little bit like the
experience of being in the room with you
at the Golden Globes is a little bit
like the tail end of a family Christmas
yes where you know it's drunk uncle yeah
yeah
do we show him where the bathroom is
did we just let him I can feel that and
I can see the tension and then when I do
a joke about them they think oh that was
all right like Leo DiCaprio was laughing
thinking he could have said a lot worse
you know that's the lovely thing for us
watching as well as the jokes are
obviously funny but then it's seen the
faces in there and how they how they
take it did you always say every joke or
did you did you ever stop yourself no I
know I uh no I I went there you know
yeah you know that's my adrenaline rush
I'm not a brave person you know so
that's that's my only that's my only
extreme sport I do saying things that
everything's in front of them I just
wondered if there was a guy who thought
oh no that's gone a bit far oh yeah I
mean most of them
you think the things I say are terrible
think of the things I think
the punk band when you were on the same
were you backstage with Madonna when you
were in a punk band uh the punk band was
in uh Atlanta Georgia okay when I
started out but uh Madonna stuff that
was New York in the early 80s and was
she like a fan of yours uh no she was a
fan of no ones but Madonna's yeah
a fan of hers yeah
didn't you audition for Madonna Benedict
oh God yes I did
and uh
yeah yeah she just sort of came in a
briefly very late and uh had a clipboard
in hand when I said yeah
Benedict Cumberbatch is that really your
name and I went yes it is Madonna
laughs
this is a breakthrough role for you jack
because
an American accent
yes I was doing an American accent well
in that clip yeah
I feel the Oscar bars
you see what a lot of actors do when
they do an American accent is they tend
to just go for like one region of
America and they commit to a single
American accent I decided with this role
that I would take Sonata around all 50
states
but sometimes in the same scene I
thought why just do one where you can
show off them all
I've seen talking like I was from New
York and then all of a sudden I'm
suddenly speaking like I'm a Cali girl
and by the end of the scene they're
stopping me because it sounds like I'm
from The Dukes of Hazard
all over the place but I thought you
know just show off your skills
[Music]